remember that game of dnd you started
when you were 11 what if it never
stopped my name is robert wordoff i'm a
history professor at the university of
western ontario i am a dungeon master
for a campaign that has been going on
for 40 years what began in secret with a
few friends has turned into a game that
takes up much of robert's life and most
of his house robert has around 30 000
hand-painted figurines countless
custom-made pieces of terrain and dozens
of devoted players taking part in his
campaign if you're going to keep a game
going for 40 years it's going to have to
be a good game if you're going to have
people who are going to want to play
that are going to want to fly in you're
going to have to offer a product that is
going to be better than all the other
alternatives they're out there i can
certainly say with confidence that this
is the best dungeons and dragons game in
the world
so if i'm playing for 10 hours a week at
52 weeks in a year that means i'm doing
that times 40 that would be 20
800 hours how many minutes is that
so if i figured that out in minutes that
would end up being 1.24
million minutes
i think
as you crest the ridge there seems to be
quite a commotion you estimate it could
be as many as two dozen or so goblins
you surprise them as much as they have
surprised you i need a surprise role
that's really just the start almost
every major decision in robert's life is
designed to keep the game going
when i was buying a house the most
important part for me was getting a
gaming space that i could use my entire
basement is my gaming area if he doesn't
slow down he's gonna need a bigger house
[Music]
i have a lot of figs i've got orcs i've
got elves i've got dwarves i've got all
the basic things that you'd expect but i
also have very distinct and unique figs
i have vampires i have undead i have
zombies i have werewolves beholders
tiamat the mother of all dragons all the
big demonic lords from the demogorgon
but also heroes so all the great kings
and queens of countries the high-level
wizards all of these things my goal is
to have everything but what's the point
of having so many figurines if you don't
have any amazing terrain to place them
on robert has no shortage in that
department either i need to be able to
adapt to wherever the party's going to
go that means that i need to have my
green terrains i need to have mountain
terrain i need to have all of my winter
terrain my air desert trains my water
trains if they're going to go into a
town now i need a town okay are they in
a roman town are they in an anglo-saxon
town are they in an african town is it
high medieval is it low medieval so now
i'm trying to be able to put out a
village or a town for every one of these
historical settings
i can't put figurines on the table
unless they are painted up to a certain
level
that means that someone's got to do a
heck of a lot of painting and so that
ends up being me if you found me on an
average day working on the game you'd
probably see me in my painting room and
i'm going to be spending two three four
hours painting figs and do people take
their figs home no
no nobody is allowed to take their
figurines home nobody is actually
allowed to touch the figs on the table
so that's also something that would be
different a person who played dungeons
and dragons would probably come to my
table and they would immediately reach
over to grab their fig i'm probably
going to growl at them and tell them
don't touch the figs because i have to
move everything i'm sure my critics
would say that there's a god complex
going on about that
this here is the figurine of the demon
lord orcas it's well known to dennis and
dragons and in my campaign a hundred
years ago which would be an actual time
something like maybe 1989
the group banished this demon so they
thought that's fine only recently last
year actually the demon's back they
don't know where he is they're
desperately trying to find him and he's
definitely up to no good
while fantasy role-playing and nerd
culture are often celebrated today
robert's campaign started during a time
when people felt like they needed to
play in secret in the 80s and 90s it was
certainly more difficult to try to talk
about or explain the game to people i
grew up in a very small town and it was
quite a conservative town and so the
town inevitably found out that we were
playing and they didn't know what the
heck we were doing and dungeons and
dragons had very bad press at the time
tonight we begin with a story about
make-believe adventure and real-life
violence and what some critics fear is a
connection between the two in a game
called dungeons and dragons a movie came
out while we were playing called mazes
and monsters and it's a story of how
they play this game and then they try to
act it out in real life and basically
bad things certainly happen
can you tell me of the giant dragon
on my travels here i heard him
what's now called the satanic panic was
going on at the time why does my son
want to play this game all the time why
is he obsessed about it what are you
doing to him are you a cult leader i got
called a cult leader a communist like
all these all these crazy labels when i
watched stranger things it obviously hit
home for me it is almost here what is it
what if it's a
demogorgon oh jesus we're so screwed if
it's the demogorgon it's not the
demogorgon the whole concept matched
exactly what we were doing in the early
1980s
over the following decades robert went
on to build a campaign of unrivaled
complexity one of the things that makes
my game unique is the story and the
depth of the campaign my world is an
alternative fantasy version of
historical earth within other historical
aspects added to it so if somebody comes
in and they want to go to athens i can
now bring in that history philosophy
religion at the end of the game i'm able
to create what i need to create come up
with totally new races totally new
nations totally new cultures totally new
mythologies but also to use what the
world already has
a typical dungeon master curates the
quest for a handful of players over the
course of a few months robert meanwhile
is tracking the adventures of more than
50 players with story arcs that often
span decades
since the beginning there's probably
been about 500 characters that have been
made and played within the game when a
new player comes in i'm inviting them to
play a game
that they're going to be welcome to keep
playing until i die so you could start a
character nine generations later that
family could take over let's say the
roman empire on one level you're playing
that individual character on a macro
level you're also controlling the roman
empire so there are numerous story arcs
that are going on many of those last for
generations there's love stories
romances there's quests there's
vengeance all these things are happening
so even though there is this large
campaign quest this large ultimate goal
you've got literally thousands of
subplots and some campaigns going on
from the beginning robert quickly
learned which rules could be bent and
which rules could be broken when we
started playing there was probably a
short period of time when i played
according to the actual rules but after
that i had to fill in holes and so i
developed my own rule system and i've
never really gone back so i have what
gamers would call a homebrew rule system
and actually that's how the game was
intended when the game first came out
one of the lines in the dungeon master
guide told you that these are a set of
rules but to apply these loosely and
within my game and my world there are
all kinds of different aspects that you
wouldn't see in an ordinary dungeons
dragon's rule system my rules are fast
they're quick flowing people don't have
to stop and check things and that speed
of gameplay is something that i find so
different in my game from ordinary
dungeons and dragons
robert strives to keep the stakes as
high as possible for his players
especially when it comes to life and
death consequences for their characters
i want death to mean something i don't
want this to be like a video game that
you simply hit the reset button and
you're just going to start a new
character so when your character dies if
you don't have any other characters then
you're out of the game the game's over
for you and so when characters die or
bad things happen i have seen growing
men weep at the table and that's
something also people who don't play are
a bit disturbed if they hear that
somebody who's been playing a character
for a long time weeps at the table but
i'm trying to create emotion i'm trying
to create excitement people are scared
and knowing that if you die you could be
out of the game or that character that
you put so much time in is now dead
obviously people's heart rates are up
there's emotion going on so i can't be
shocked and surprised when that
character dies that there's a show of
emotion
okay
i have one daughter and ever since she
was a baby she's been around this i
think maybe when she was six or seven
was the first time when she asked
whether she could play so she created a
character as a fairy and she still plays
now she's 20 years old i mean obviously
there's other stuff going on in her life
but she's been playing all the way
through the interesting thing happens
when she starts dating and then her
boyfriend wants to play and of course i
have to tell her straight off they go
now this relationship may not last
forever but the game's gonna last
forever so get ready because i'm
anticipating a situation when you break
up with him i can't break up with him so
once i allow somebody to come into the
game i'm never ever going to stop them
from playing the game so sure enough
that situation happened so it can be a
little bit awkward at times but it means
a lot to be able to have my daughter
play the game and to have her interested
in the game and she obviously knows what
the game means to me uh for sure
i think there's an assumption that at
some point we're all going to grow up
and we're going to stop playing games
and so people will say how does your
game end how's it going to end and it's
like well my answer is always how does
the world end how is your world gonna
end well it's probably gonna end when i
die well for you it is right and so the
answer is largely the same it's much
like life
more than anything else the game
represents friendship and i find that
friendship is based on planks you need
something to hold it together so we may
have gone to high school together but as
we go through our lives unless we have a
plank we're not gonna get together we're
not gonna fly to see each other so as
long as i can keep doing it hopefully
for all of my life i won't lose my
friends
my basement's my sanctuary it's a place
that i can come and i can almost as soon
as i walk down here i am in a different
world and it opens up all the doors of
creativity i don't ever intend on
stopping playing on stopping painting on
stopping building and on stopping
bringing my friends together to play the
game i don't ever intend
on quitting